honey and welcome to the episode number
8 of the Google APIs on podcast I'm
Franciscan boy and I'm here with my
co-host mark modèle hey Mark how are you
doing I'm good thanks how you doing
Francesca pretty good pretty good back
to San Francisco and enjoying the the
awesome weather yeah I'm back in San
Francisco to it's a little bit warmer
than where I've been previously so yeah
I got that I remember you were in
Vancouver so yeah I can imagine so uh we
have a very interesting episode coming
today we're gonna be interviewing uh one
of our dear teammates yes Philippe
Philippe alpha he's he's a developer
advocate for the group cloud platform
like both of us but he specializes in
big data yeah he does some really
interesting stuff with Vieira so we're
gonna be talking about big data what is
big data why is it cool what can you do
with it what can you do regarding big
data on Google cloud platform okay yes
so hot right now yeah I think it can be
really interesting yeah and we're gonna
try to discuss as much as possible but
again p people have extra questions
we're always interested on those
definitely if people want to get in
contact with us what's hit them up right
now let's go with that so if i remember
correctly it's on twitter it's at gcp
podcast yup on reddit we have a
subreddit R / gcp podcast yep there's
the same thing we have a web page it's
gcp podcast com we have an email hello
JCB podcast come and you can find us on
google+ ass gcp yeah it's possible I see
the podcast yeah there we go easy
wonderful so yes if you have any
questions or anything else you want to
send to us please do we love to get the
comments and feedback yeah cool so
before we start with the interview to
our dear colleague Philippe let's talk
about the cool thing of the week whether
we have a very cool cool thing of the
week they were a little biased of course
um it's that we took a pretty cool
product but we decide
just to make it better I know the joke
it doesn't really work with your accent
knows it doesn't work with an accent so
currently in beta is always better oh
god I've just ruined it but yes we have
version 2 of our cloud sequel product do
we want to talk a little bit about what
cloud sequel is sure so cloud sequel is
basically just my sequel on the cloud
yeah that's really much what it is it
has some really cool features like the
fact that you don't need to care about
that instance working that's on us here
you basically say hey I need one
instance running and if there's any
patches or security or whatever needs to
be done it's google engineers will do
that for you yeah and if you want to
like replicate it and do that stuff like
that it's sort of just push button you
just really yeah so everything is
basically it's like a self-driving my
sequel instance on the cloud I got to
say that's nice and and now we have
version 2 which is in beta and better
you see with my accident with your
accent that works i totally so what's
what's new in the with the beta version
so basically it is really it is just
better so it's a lot faster I have a
number here it was bleep up to seven
times faster than the cone the current
version which is which is pretty good
and you know like you don't really have
to do very much above and beyond that
and also takes it scales out a whole lot
better up to 20 times the storage
capacity of the first generation yeah I
actually saw there's a graphic will will
put that in the show notes to you but
there's a graphic where he shows how
much it scales and when you have when
you have enough traffic we're having 64
course helps you're gonna see that it
scales it's it's much much faster it is
able to have way higher transaction per
second command yeah if you one there's
also yeah storage it used to be 500
gigabytes which is decent that's all
right nice 10 terabytes that's pretty
decent which is pretty decent that's
that's decent amount of Veda indeed so
yeah that and that's pretty much it it's
still beta so it's not all the features
are still not there yeah but we're
working on them yep so if you're
interested
on my sequel and on the cloud just give
it a try yes know how it goes yeah it's
pretty straightforward when you go to
create your instance just choose second
generation and where you go awesome
great so let's go with our interview
totally bang so we're here with our
colleague Philippe it hi Philippe hello
Frances hello mark so these fairly be
hopeful ah there was a little bit about
yourself Felipe who are you what do you
do my name is Felipe Hoffa I've been a
cloud developer advocate hello um I talk
a lot about big data especially bigquery
i started at Google almost five years
ago five years ago I will interview in
at this stage I started as a software
engineer nice like me actually not like
me not like you yeah we all have a
similar story and then two years later i
joined the developer relations team and
I became a software engineer with our
license to speak with the lashes I like
that that's very much I said it first
yeah great so you said that you talked a
lot about big data so we're gonna ask
you just to do that tell us what is big
data for you at least what is big data
yeah yeah yeah a lot of people have
tried to define what is big data yeah so
what's your the finish what is the
definition like actually is the absolute
definition okay we're we are good you
know how we call big data google data
data it being big it's a very weird
concept data has no size or weight some
people are called big data problems that
are complicated or for example i love
tell asking people when i go to a
conference who here works in big data
normally people have no idea if they do
hey okay uh
but then I have some questions like who
knows sequel people who have no sequel
are people that are working with data
with databases fair enough and then my
next question is who had had her queries
that ran for more than an hour for a day
or that simply don't run okay I can see
ya okay and that's when we enter a
different domain where problems are
taking a long time with problems are
complex to solve at least with the
technologies they know okay okay so
rather than look at it from like this is
how much like terabytes or petabytes or
millions of rows rather look at it from
the perspective I've got a problem I
need to solve it when it has to do with
data but it's gonna take me three hours
a day a week given the tools that I have
at my disposal exactly that's what
people think oh this is a big data
problem yeah then we have the Google way
of solving problems here we bring the
same problem here with technologies we
have created developed here and the same
problem that might take you days using
your standard tool kit might take you
three seconds yeah nice so so big data
finally it's not really about the size
of the data is really about how much
time it takes you to solve a problem in
and how like standard techniques at some
point they just not they just don't work
anymore right yeah so so what kind of
techniques do you use then most of
techniques at this time it's about what
tools for a while to be able to manage
terabytes of data billions of rows
people have to learn new technologies we
have for example MapReduce Hadoop spark
Pig etc but then there is a lot of
complexity there you need to wrap your
mind around using parallel servers using
developing policy
but sometimes you just want to count
things you just want to know what are
your top customers or how things are
changing so instead of going through all
these technologies today you can use
technology like bigquery when you just
load your data ask your questions with
sequel and you get the answer in seconds
without having to learn a whole new
mindset okay so you mentioned that that
one of the things that we do at Google
is we have internal problems we solve
them and then we put them as available
to anyone else outside is be quite one
of those yeah well historically we've
been publishing all these papers the
MapReduce paper etc etc etc we live
through that yes and one of those papers
is driven how do we process terabytes of
data using sequel at scale yeah and that
people's planes the whole detail of how
do we parallelize estas without making
it okay well put that definition it yeah
yes so interesting oh yeah historically
we release the papers and the world
rushes to implement them with open
source implementations but now we have a
cloud now we make these services the
same services we use internally
available for everyone oh yeah that's
what we're doing with bigquery that the
service that implement the rebel paper
that's something I actually heard the
story about drama I don't know if it's
true or if it's just like a legend but I
heard about the fact that when dremel
was created at Google to process 24
hours of logs was taking almost 24 hours
lots of logs which means that like it's
taking processing one our logs takes
more than one hour then you can at some
point you're gonna lose blood I guess
that isn't true like a good dremel solve
that problem let go of a sudden instead
of hours you go down to minutes or
seconds yes yes I have no idea if that
is true or i know it's true for many
customers
I know I know people that are working
with huge data sets that were only able
to process a small percentage of the
logs through processes but vanillite and
fail during the night and suddenly they
try to Clarion well yeah it takes five
seconds no baby ceiling of processes or
anything so bigquery really is like an
example of what you're talking about
before people struggling up against
walls of how much time like purchasing
was gonna take and certainly going from
hours days weeks down to seconds yes
yeah and without involving any special
knowledge it's just a sequel yes is it
yes we're just talking about data you
have data you have questions yeah that's
it so how do you how do you put that
data in bigquery their two main ways one
is touch it if you have a CSV or JSON
files yeah you can load them into Google
Cloud storage if they are big enough so
it's good to go through google cloud
storage when you have very big files you
start up there and be query can easily
ingest files from these places o or also
be query can ingest streaming data so if
you have any stream of real-time data
coming you can load up to a hundred
thousand rows per second into one big
query tale that sounds a lot like what
we're discussing last episode about
messaging we're talking about cloud pops
up yeah is that the way to stream data
into bigquery that's one way no cloud
pub/sub doesn't output data straight
into bigquery okay um don't ask me why
but maybe one day lovely well yeah one
of our customers wrote a very nice blog
post where they use pops up to ingest a
lot of streaming data and define a lot
of course into bigquery yeah now in the
middle day you start flow Oh interesting
is Google Cloud dataflow actually since
we're ready
discussing about cloud dataflow so
bigquery is one of the products that
with you can do big data processing with
Google cloud platform what about cloud
dataflow what is the difference and why
would you use one or the other yeah so
if you have data you have questions that
you can express with simple require is
the place okay go now with data flow we
are able to solve different kinds of
problems like where you would call you
would use Java code to write more
complicated stages and is it more like
mapreduce or yeah data flow is the new
MapReduce we publish the MapReduce paper
like 10 years ago yeah maybe morning
dream so alaga yeah yeah and since then
we published two very interesting papers
one is floom floom Java yeah and that
talks about how we orchestrate these
pipelines of my producers and optimize
them on the way and also they milk will
paper that deals with streaming data and
data flow is what it's our service that
encapsulate these two weeks okay how do
we write a smart pipe line of my profuse
processes so MapReduce has this problem
if you really want your MapReduce
processes to go fast you have to do a
lot of manual optimization okay and data
flow takes care of that and you just
write your pipelines as you could write
them mentally and then the optimization
is part of the process you don't have to
care about optimizing things manually so
what sort of things would i be using
data for for like if i can get my data
into bigquery and process it they're
like can you give me an example of like
is it like real time or is it like what
sort of stuff am i doing with data flow
yes so data flow has 22 volts what is
the
a budget boat I can wear this is
streamable so what's the difference oh
yes to be for us it was different okay a
part of the charm of data flow is that
your same code good work for both types
of data okay usually people have to deal
with one system for button processing
what system for streaming processes with
a tough low you can do both um just to
give you a simple example of what I've
used data flow for em when I found some
web logs that were in binary format that
i wanted to load into the query I need
to write some code I the logs were
massive it was billions of rows so I had
to process any parallel so i could write
just a simple script in java inside data
flow and data flow took care of doing
this process of splitting it and ran it
into many different servers okay so
using a series of detailed
transformations hopefully just massive
data transformations that data flow
takes care of the parallelization yes
making this process smart but what
really brilliant about data flow tools
how it treats streaming data yeah so I
mentioned that you can stream data into
bigquery and you can analyze it light up
immediately worries but sometimes you
want to run some online algorithms I
love the Wikipedia example where you can
look at the changelog so how many what
pages are people changing at any given
time and the question there is from a
stream of like you have a list of what
pages are changing which paid at any
time how can you find what our relevant
news hmm interesting yes so how can you
tell this change is important versus the
change is not yeah so you can do
something quite similar like trending
topics on Twitter and stuff like that
and that's really interesting make sense
yeah so there's a good
well Thomas Tyner that wrote a paper on
this and he looks at three things this
page how many changes with Paige have
had in the last minute yep and how many
different people are are changing it
okay and there was a third factor that I
so it's how many changes help people
many people learn how frequent are these
changes yeah once we suppose those
thresholds we can say oh now we have
something interesting like we have 50
people at the same time doing it yeah I
would love to run that algorithm on a
stream of it just to get real-time
results yeah that'd be really
interesting I can even imagine using
that for monitoring of your own
application like trying to understand
like the same thing we are do monitoring
on Google cloud platform over logs and
see like oh maybe the traffic is too
high send me an alarm or you can do
something more advanced like business
metrics yeah basically how much money
think so like being being spent and
their products being sold to answer
stuff so you with data flow you have the
ability to define some rules yeah over
some windows a short time and it makes
it very very easy to start defining that
kind of processes now I wanna play with
data slim oh oh yes the data flow is
actually the only reason why I've ridden
Java lately yeah which you know it's
gonna yeah that's a big statement for me
we also know sir I felt better flow yeah
I heard about that but still not there
so again okay right you are like the
mint ok so we've discussed two things
bigquery and cloud dataflow I know and
now that you mentioned Python you made
me think about it it's the cloud data
lab they come up that a lot yes yeah if
any for you depending on which accident
and are you gonna go with yeah by the
way action wise today we're doing great
we have acquired a whole set but we're
getting good we're famous I didn't tell
people where I come from but
let them guess oh yeah that's there we
go just big data analysis to guess where
Felipe's from so yeah tell us about
cloud data lab yes so if you have used a
ipython notebooks I've done it yeah they
go yes and you should call them now the
Jupiter notebooks okay I will that's the
Phantom their actual name now okay okay
okay i buy some split this project
between I python and the notebook and
now it's the Jupiter not to because they
support many more languages it's not
Python specific ah nice yes okay I
didn't know that did not an arena so you
the Jupiter names come from Julia Python
are that would make sense yep soaking
like that yeah cool so if you take those
books I love them they're great way for
data scientist to work with cold date
editor if you take those notebooks how
can we make them us package the message
service how could we have a service that
immediately deploy some bubble for you
takes care of storage of storing leave
them on our repository and take care it
takes care of authentication with the
different Google services and basically
the Google cloud data lab it's our an
easy way to deploy manage and work with
Google service inside Jupiter notebook
so if I'm like I was I have all this
data I want to integrate it with some
big data tools but I want to like work
in like say a Python environment or in
our environment something like that and
get like maybe nice visualizations that
sort of thing that's that's a pretty
good environment for that yes I diluted
cool interactive environment yeah you
could do the same at home with your
Jupiter notebooks but then you need to
take care of everything installing them
authentication between your computer and
a server with this they're just running
there
yeah I love it that sounds really
powerful especially for education and
things like that where basically you
want to teach someone statistics and you
have data it's like you can share it
that's all very interesting yeah it's
one of the best ways we have now to tell
people this is how you can go with eight
a Google there are some very interesting
notebooks for example for working with
genomics oh we have a lot of genomics
data bigquery and the university has
published very cool data lab notebooks
that's really cool especially what I
like is that basically it allows you to
do processing on what people already
used to like many people that the data
science they do they use Python and they
used to use ipython now they use pupa to
Peter so basically having the
possibility of doing the same thing but
having been powered by the cloud and
having access to do you have also access
to be query yeah okay so you have access
to be query do you have access not to
cloud dataflow cuz that's a different
technology that's completely different
but what about faith Python better flow
Oh interesting so again you can you
actually combine all of those things on
one single Jupiter hunt thing you should
be able to go again we're moving forward
to getting that cool just a yeah a
little Leo announcement would not be an
announcement but the cloud data lab is
still in beta yeah if people want to
play with it go see it and give your
feedback like when you give feedback
about data product is when your feedback
is gonna be really taken into account so
if you have strong opinions about the
product let us know yes please try it
out its most of it is open source so
it's from you can find it on github you
can fire feature requests you can send
patches if you follow the whole how to
contribute go to Google steps nice
that's very cool now i'm looking here
apparently I'm we currently support what
is a Python sequel and JavaScript for
bigquery user-defined functions
yes hmm but it's also like pay for the
resources you use so you could fire this
up and then run with it and shut it down
yeah that's pretty cool yeah actually
nice cool so okay so so far we've seen
then on cloud now cloud dataflow cloud
data lab and bigquery is there any other
products that you think we should
mention I mean we also mentioned pops up
quite quickly right is there anything
else that you go back to mention God
it's just fun to see so many different
names that people have to remember yeah
there they will all be in the show notes
yeah usually when i say bigquery people
that remember big table for some reason
oh i should we talk about the table we
should mention big table victorville is
awesome big table is also another
technology that from the beginnings of
google we publish a paper they worked
took those papers they produce soft open
source software based on it like HDFS
and cassandra and then many years later
we are offering big time plus a service
nice it's HDFS compatible yeah that's
really cool I mean I think that anyone
that has been working at Google as a
software engineer like one of the things
that you get to do is you get to write
stuff on BigTable it's such an amazing
thing to have that I'm actually really
excited to be able to use it from the
outside now you can basically write your
own project that uses big table that's
gonna be okay very nice yes not to be
confused with bigquery yeah safe right
products yeah so we have two bigs and
two theta so we have bigquery a big data
data lab and data flow thank you mean
bigquery big table oh yeah that's a big
gray be credible data cloud data ah data
flow and the lab data lab there you go
okay at least none of this name sound
like Pokemon yeah that's a good that's
good oh great so uh let's talk num not
anymore about tools like the tools I
think we pretty much done
I'd like to talk a little bit about what
cool things you've seen with big data
like what cool data sets or white coat
projects you've heard about okay the
coolest one for me um is not not many
people can do things with it but just
now with the people are doing genomics
stuff with bigquery for the genomics
problems with sequel I've actually seen
a video of you analyzing your own genome
and so funny sweet yes so what is what's
genomics actually has obviously
something to do a DNA yeah so my
favorite story here is when I met
Jacqueline collar one of our site said
she knew yeah she had joined Google like
three months previous and we were meant
to the same event and with a guy she
told me that she already knew me because
when she was interviewing to work at
Google she had been watching my videos
ok and she used one of those videos to
prepare a presentation for hey google
the interview and that's how she was
hired so thankful yeah now I felt it was
a little unfair because she already knew
me and I knew not nothing on him so we
started talking then she told me about
how she loves genome is how she got her
own 23 Emmy reads so now she had her own
genome sequences yeah 23 meters all the
a small portion feet per second it's
super cool and she had already loaded
into bigquery okay and so I after will
have you analyzed it have you done
anything with it she was like not yet
and I after do you want to because I
already knew what kind of queries we
could run on her jeans that'sthat's a a
whole new meaning to getting to know
someone yeah I'm not kidding but that's
good exactly sure what sort of queries
can you run so have fun oh yeah it's
like half an hour later after meeting
her analyzing her teens and the basic
you don't have to say the answers but I
need help okay yeah so they are open
databases of what each gene what each
thing read meals so you can start
running Joyce hey let's take your
special specific genes yeah yes yeah
let's do it with this other table that
says what each means yeah let's start
looking at love who are you crying so we
could be like all right let's take my
jeans look Francesca jeans and see if we
somehow have a common ancestor you
probably have a commoner figure yeah
long time ago I don't know or maybe no
nothing come on yeah no but you can see
things like you know that there are
people that can not tolerate eatin
cilantro oh yeah and one of those yeah
and that's a genetic thing yeah that's
yeah you can see them yeah we could just
be quickly to find out if the
probability of you like insulin now I
want to play with that yeah that's
really awesome can you twist your tongue
that's another perfectly fine is
basically that's like if you didn't do
it would be quite like that could be a
decent amount of data like I don't know
if it's big data but it's a lot yeah so
you could take quite a long time how
long did it take to run like to run one
query that could tell you if I like
cilantro or not with recorded takes
seconds we're a very fast at four I have
the ability to sit down with him and a
very like cilantro answer now you know
her really well well kind of in a way
but yeah so I had to tweet about this is
that one yeah that's all I remember and
then William Bob any pair we're proud
manager replied to that plate and his
kid was hey I just met you and this is
crazy but here are my jeans so sequel
then maybe maybe I should ask you to
sing that but nah that's not gonna do it
right any any other cool big data say
that
like there's so much public data open
data available now and this year I've
enjoyed playing with taxi data all the
taxi trips in New York and visualizing
what happens inside a city or also
social media sites having the full story
of only 1.9 billion reddit comments and
that's a lot of media they were
collected by users stuck in the matrix
from readied and then he published them
the comments I took them and now they're
a big query so now we can analyze so are
they are they a public data center gank
anyone can just go and start play with
that yes right now great just load the
queria use your free monthly terabyte of
analysis and just stop running queries
one free terabyte yes with a tee wow we
data that's yeah that's big data okay oh
that's why you don't either anyone can
go and play with these data sets okay so
how can use if you want to see the
difference on github okay we'll put a
link to that on the show notes that is
pretty fun are there any other places
you recommend if people want to go like
looking for big data open set data or is
that giving away your special source of
where you find myself personally love
Brandi yeah I even started one sub ready
/ r / bigquery yeah so all the open data
sets that I know of that I've been
playing with any stories I know related
with the query I put it there perfect so
go see everything I know ready / are
flat be quick wiring awesome wonderful
well it was there anything else that we
haven't covered that you want to
necessarily throw in there about big
data or bigquery or data flow I guess
you will have me I get here I'm sure we
can do that at some point I guess so
well thank you so much for being here
and dr. using thank you thank you very
much to Felipe for joining us for this
interview today i found that
particularly interesting I don't do a
huge amount of big data stuff so that
was really great hearing about all the
products and all the things that he's
been working on yeah that was lots of
fun lots of fun but we have a really
interesting question of the week you
again start with a conversation i had
with andrew watson he was talking about
sort of environment variables in a
engine and it sort of expanded from
there into sort of I've got like a
password or a credential or a secret key
you know I need to store their that
somewhere safe within Google cloud
platform and be able to share that with
a variety of services what sort of the
ways I can do that or maybe even just
what's the best way of doing that now I
know you've got some opinions on this
France asked I do have some opinions
yeah so yeah so it really depends on
what you actually doing so I know that
for instance if you're an app engine
yeah there is app engine environment
variables that's trip that works very
well but it will be available only for
App Engine yep if you're in Cooper
Nettie's my secrets yeah there's govern
a secret yeah so that's that's a very
good solution when you are running
everything we could burn at ease but by
default my my go-to way of storing stuff
secret but not only secrets also
configuration and yeah all of those
things that you want to share across all
the agents of your system yeah is the
military service oh that's sounds
interesting tell me more about what that
is so it's in something really simple
it's basically a way to store metadata
like key value pairs evaluate exactly so
you have a key which is a string and
then a value which is a strength that's
it cool and the good thing about it is
that it's actually very safe okay it's
very simple to use it has it has a REST
API and it uses authentication yep so
all too so you're gonna need some scopes
to access it on everything but if you're
doing it from inside of compute engine
by default you're already authorized to
do it cuz nice you're actually we're
going to be hitting an internal endpoint
yeah so even just curl will work for you
if you're doing it from outside of
compute engine you will need to use the
rest api that then allows you to access
the same API but with authentication oh
that's really cool so I only thought you
could access the metadata stuff
basically from within
compute engine but you're saying like we
can actually access that from anywhere I
did that too I did think so too and
actually while preparing this podcast
one of our colleagues Sandeep show that
that we were wrong which is awesome
that's great I love being wrong it
actually makes a mixer life much easier
basically you just keep all your data in
the computer engine made at their
service yep and you can access it from
wherever you want that's really really
handy hustad whatever you want in there
and yes need to know it yet it's secure
goes it's encrypted both ways a nun
storage too it's incredibly simple yeah
it's in question not only it's addressed
so once we saw we stored encrypted but
also in France it so well it's going
from the service to your instance it
will also be encrypted there so it's
really really simple to use if you had
older other things that you wanted to
share like they were like imagine it's
not just a symp something quite small
it's like I don't know a big file or
something that you want to keep secret
then probably Google Cloud Storage every
weapons way to do it because you don't
you have limitations on the size you can
keep whatever you want and it's also
very secure and equipped it it's gonna
require your authentication and you have
the same things just bigger by the same
token I suppose you could also use data
store or even cloud sequel if you really
wanted to yeah yeah but it sounds like
the metadata API I mean that sounds like
it's kind of built for the stuff that's
like a really good solution it's the
simplest way to do it and yeah I guess
that the one of the cool things of this
is that yeah it also works outside of
compute engine so you can access this
through rest api ice that is very very
cool yeah awesome well this is the last
episode of the year to shed a little of
a TM moment I'm a little bit sad dadless
invites me oh yeah I'm gonna miss you
for the next few weeks but we're
definitely coming back in 2016 yeah
we're coming back the beginning of next
year for
I'm better more better we've got a very
exciting interview lined up but I don't
I don't want to say what it is we're
gonna keep it secret but I think it's
gonna be really awesome it's about
something that I really like yep so no
no it's not got none of a girl thought
about go okay ya go maybe we should do
something about go do it but yeah it's
gonna be really interesting and with
someone that really knows what he's
talking about so I'm very excited about
it sounds good sounds cuz they're
definitely people check in with us in
2016 yeah uh so let's see you soon in
two weeks see you all soon we've
finished now with our eighth episode
yeah and hoping for many more to come
next year definitely i'll see you next
year see ya
hey I just met you and this is paying
for his ID a force equal me maybe OOP